day six of the candidates in
Yekaterinburg Russia with a clear leader
finally merging eight of the world's
best players were back on stage to fight
for precious wins
Jelena poem that she defeated China's
ding Lauren in a wild affair allowing
the Russian superstar to extend his lead
to a full point over his nearest rival
it's number one against number two in a
match of that kinetic history's round
seven of exciting action coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to Round seven of the 2020
candidates from Yekaterinburg Russia it
is the tournament to determine the
Challenger to Magnus Carlsen for the
world champion title hopefully later
this year i'm grandmaster alejandro meet
us here in the studio with grandma sir
yes sir sarah one who is now 60 years
old not too much different from
yesterday that's for sure
hello everyone and welcome to our 20/20
coverage of the candidates the first
three rounds were fantastic topsy-turvy
Affairs but then the last three rounds
have been perfect for neppo Yan is the
one who is practicing his social
distancing as he stands clear in the
tables let's take a look at Leandro at
the standings after six rounds of play
it's not just half a point it's a full
point that he asked on the field and
actually over just one other player
Maxime Michela Graf is the only other
person with A+ scorer in the tournament
three and a half points they're facing
each other today max even with the white
piece is certainly a crucial game for
the tournament and when you want to look
at that way chess history absolutely and
four players tied at 50% from Fabiana
five young down to an age two players in
final position and what does story what
a shocking story is DHing luring
absolutely a hopeful for the title
everybody has to be singing his praises
for the last half of 2019 yeah very well
the surface an unbelievable run he's
just not finding his point here now
let's take a look at the format in your
captain book it's a double round-robin
that means that's 14 rounds of chess
everybody gets equal amounts of whites
and blacks and it's a very long time
control a hundred minutes for the first
40 moves 50 minutes for the next 20 and
15 minutes once you reach move 60 so
plenty of time to think and if that
wasn't enough you still get your 30
seconds
move from one no draw offers on blacks
voting until blacks 40th move and of
course half a million you're a surprise
fun that nobody's looking at because
everybody cares about that one spot
that's victory and that everything else
will taste like the P exactly a
challenger or bust and everybody should
be familiar with our schedule but let's
just take another peek at what it looks
like three games an arrest date three
gates and arrest day and today is the
first of three we had arrested yesterday
to join us today Jonas tomorrow join is
a day after and on March 28th we will
have the next arrests a wonderful let's
go directly to the breaking news of the
round with Maurice Ashley
well thank you Alejandro and indeed we
have a huge matchup between numbers one
and two in the tournament number two
being Maxine by Sheila Groff he has the
white pieces against Yanukovych II and
it looks right now like Yan is in big
trouble take a look at this position it
all started back here with a standard
maneuver in the winner of French where
this move queen g4 taxed upon and rook
g8 defending it assuring castling rights
of course he couldn't cast immediately
because of Bishop h6 but Bishop b5 King
f8 and you wonder did this guy forget
how to castle the way the king and the
rook replace well that lasted all the
way of course it's hard to fix and at
the moment you see this position you say
black looks like he's down a rook he's
got to fix the situation to the move c4
shutting down any activity on this side
and it Maxime said no problem our Castle
play Queen c2 how are you gonna solve
this problem rook h8 the last move look
like that rook it's never moved but he's
wasting time here
trying to figure this out you know
White's gonna try to crash through on
the Queen side while I had that entire
rook this is definitely a problem for
neppo and he's also feeling it on the
clock he's at 47 he's not way down
against Maxime but you don't want to be
on the defensive side of this position
we know he's traditionally a very fast
player well let's take a look as this is
indeed the game of the day but look at
the score Maxime without 5 to 1 scorer
with seven drawers that's huge that's
that's saying I got your
number maxime has defeated him in a
critical game in the last round before
right here in st. Louis to win the
Sinquefield Cup he also has not done so
more recently not winning a big game but
that was not a last round of here this
is not a last round of here I should say
this is simply round seven but it could
be huge for this tournament I mean
absolutely massive because he would tie
nepo and all the other chasers would
feel like they were back in it as well
let's take a look at Maxine's path to
this point as he has won only one game
he was in a little bit of trouble in a
couple of them the one against Caruana
and so bad he was able to handle that
position but the big miss that he had
against Gris Chuck that was certainly a
low light for him he had a win on the
board he could have crushed his opponent
that would have given him the full
pointy end up only drawing that game he
needs to get points it's not gonna be
enough to score plus one and somebody
who's saying takers thinking plus one
I'm trying to run away with this event
already on plus three is the public eye
as you see there he's got four and a
half that's out of six plus three
already that's a massive score
absolutely after drawing the first round
and after winning the first round during
the next three and then bang bang two
wins in a row is he uncatchable well the
history of this tournament says yes the
four candidates played in this 14 round
format have featured only one comeback
that has featured all comebacks of half
a point at most half a point has been
the biggest lead any player who has
established a full point lead has gone
on to win the tournament
well it's only round seven so calling
him completely uncatchable seems maybe a
bit early but I'll tell you
netball take it so will his fans in
Russia we'll see though because this
game looks like he's in a little bit of
trouble thank you look at the rest of
the parents we also have other important
matchups two matches of 50% players
playing against each other I do
if they're gonna make any headlines to
determine they want to really put
pressure on either MVL or nipple
whoever's coming out ahead does have to
win today exactly those two games are
between Fabian way now and on nishan
alexander Grichuk as those four players
are all at 50% and that's just not going
to get it done you're not going to
become a challenger unless you went put
together some wings
there we see mvl and then finally being
Larry and Carol somebody's going to say
okay I don't want to be last right hey
you take you take the place but with
minus two for both players it is
difficult to imagine that they're really
the Challenger exactly at this moment I
think they're just looking for a decent
result right into the action I think we
have to go into the MBL game it is the
game of the day of course mention that
it was a do-or-die match that they had
in Jerusalem because exactly the one
that Maurice was right from referencing
because despite the fact that mvl is
here he's made it through some not
Orthodox method let's say right but java
withdrew from the tournament
I mean 7vl got the other spot but
remember net would knocked out and BL
from this tournament by defeating him in
Jerusalem has it been the other way
around and VL would be here at net but
wouldn't right nepalese MBL is here
anyway but that was through extenuating
circumstances indeed indeed and the game
much to my surprise Yanis is staying
with his French defense a very risky
opening I think so as well I mean and
it's certainly not popular the most
elite levels at club levels the club
players love the French but this
particular variation and when you look
at it you know this castling the
situation that Maurice referencing
referenced earlier just doesn't feel
like black ever really got equality
because he never sold his King sight
problem the last move we're really
telling
rook h8 coming from McLean h7 as being
necessarily a threat but maybe it's just
one of those things that
neppo just didn't know what to do a3 a4
very important you know very standard
type
move and also sets up four moves like a
rootless rupee five rook before to be
one the bishop on d2 you can imagine it
going to a three it's gonna have a
beautiful diagonal there exactly as
we've seen so often on many of those
winter words yeah the dark square bishop
at the moment looks like impotent bishop
it's not doing anything other than
attacking h6 suddenly you put the bishop
on a3 and it becomes a it's more as a
French player myself I know when the
bishop gets there yeah it's not the end
of the world but you really have to
start being careful any night job will
just be absolutely fatal in this
specific position I'm gonna challenge
you
alejandro you've got this rook on h8 how
do you solve it well he saw that he's
trying to solve it in a very mysterious
way he played Keeney eight he did he
yeah after a four obviously preparing
Castle to Castle so you think he's gonna
play keno ed8 c8 I don't know I don't
see any other point for the move King EA
I I think he's just trying to get that
King out of the way I'm like the way
this board I'm seeing right here yeah
you made the point about rook h8 yes if
you try that maneuver you just play it
and then you finally move your rook
Queen eight seven is laying in wait so
if we for example after King EE I go G
three you go a king here I go King G -
I'm just making some moves for white so
we can demonstrate a point that is you
you you've traded already booked me
about one did ya yeah this move happens
you're gonna have to put your robe back
on g8 exactly you don't want to trade
off a pair all the rooks because Queen
Queen to h7 will will will simply win
the pawn right there'll be issues
there'll be nobody to defend a knight
that five will be met by g4 and we
already have a move the move Ruby for
played by after King II and after King
aid which a for setup it looks
incredibly logical you just cannot take
them before the blockading square we'll
see 3 will be 2 power tonight will
appear on on c3 though the monster
terrible monsters in the past pawns
the only thing you could say about this
is you hope that you can get your you
the way and maybe but I'm gonna bring
your rookie but even then like we need
something thread keeps being there so
he'll have two things to work with the
the queenside majority and the weakness
on g7 although let's note that the
c-pawn gets passed again like nepo did
against Geary maybe he'll hope against
hope that that c parm will have some
value but i think you're right alejandra
the blockading square just looks but it
doesn't repeat for invite the tempo
gaining 96 the question is can I give up
my rook right can I just go to room DB 1
okay apparently not that's a lot of
position is a lot of huh that's a lot
yeah and I was thinking go b5 Bishop
before Knight c3 and I'm just gonna
crush you something like this that was
my plan I like that plan that's a
great-looking plan that's a French it's
a really really bad eh-eh it actually
makes a very bad impression you make an
exchange up I just want to toss this C
pawn so I can pretend to have
compensation that's at least an open
file but it looks like you're the one
who's gonna benefit from this move right
because but what am I supposed to do the
position is horrible no I agree I do
think that after 96 route DB 1 is a very
serious alternative and exacting that
this one room p5 might win you have to
be very careful yeah I'm not gonna I'm
not trading I'm thinking that any trades
just invites that into the game see one
here yeah I was hoping that you wouldn't
do that
so with this queen h7 if I go to mission
may 3 check new thing has to go back and
then are you ready to join I'm
definitely ready to join her we were
talking about yeah it's awesome bishop
basics again
ok we do see real issues in front of our
tournament leader let's look at
Fabiano's game again fabio comes in as
the number one seed whoa ok this came
out of a petrov and a very big
theoretical duel i want to say is taking
place here
between Faby and Wang Hao and we get to
this position I think this is a very
good move by the way by right now trade
on f6
yeah and Knight takes f6 Bishop takes f6
was the engine suggestion I saw that
while we were getting ready for the show
alright but actually it looks very
logical this Bishop on e7 and I know I
know its positions actually rather well
because we practice them over and over
again for the world on the opposite
spectrum aronia with buck I was about to
say it just feels a little awkward that
this Bishop on e7 is suddenly a tactical
target I like it was very surprising how
often giving up the pair of fishes was
the best and easiest way to equality in
these positions and that just makes a
lot of sense to me Bishop takes you're
keeping the F file up and maybe on a
good day this night actually gets
rerouted not to have six pitaya for
Bishop h4 9 f4 could be on blacks agenda
what happened was after Knight takes f6
Bishop g5 okay that's a little bit
unexpected as well well there was a
computer s Klein start looking with 95
which looked really really promising the
idea was to exploit the e6 square on it
if it was white this turned for example
we'll put h6 on the board a logical move
in case out of the night asks you what
do you actually want to do with it and
what we want to do is play see for so
that this night could end up on the e6
square like if you wanted to really be
cooperative this would be one way of
losing the game very quickly yeah but by
the point the pawn gets to d5 things
I've already gone wrong for black Samara
bishops more importantly your structure
on the King side is weakened I have
control over the g6 square which I guess
and the other variations that gives me
the e-file so a lot of the little
strategical details that have changed
for sure
and Maurice back over to you for some
breaking news in our game
and we have seen that move Knight to c6
has occurred this is what's sitting on
the board we can't imagine nepo blood
rook before I'm sorry and be outplayed
worked - before he didn't notice nipples
responsive Knight to c6 that it was too
obvious the kick on his rook and we are
waiting for this move work to be won
this one would just be fabulous the
engine of the first say well the way
you're giving away in exchange but
slowly but surely you see the book this
thermometer or barometer go up and if
you capture in fact I'm gonna tell you
it's so bad the engine skipper okay six
complete joke to see that Mowgli but I
do get the idea is to take and you won't
be able to take back with the pawn is to
be able to Queen takes on a four so that
is a very subtle point as you look at it
further and maybe you get your night to
be six so maybe that's his plan because
capturing looks like a complete disaster
after pawn takes your queen dropping
back and the move of b5 being possible
Queen back and this Bishop to b4 it just
just looks horrible you're down a full
rook in this position and the pieces of
streaming in too easily so will he find
will he plan to find this move and
actually mvl decided on a different
route instead of doubling on the file
what a move after 96 he said let me
attack you for I don't care you can have
my rook ending this part is not hanging
takes takes and takes obviously loses
material to Queen 2 C 3 so that is
unplayable he's just ready to sacrifice
the exchange no problem at all after
Knight to c6 and he's played this very
aggressive f5 I mean I like that move to
if if you're not gonna break through on
this file why not go after her f5 how
does the guys slow you down with you not
just left he seven talk about drawback
chest he left the f5 square alone let's
go get him let's open up the position
and go after him if this happens and a
capture Queen lands on g6 open file here
nice going to f4 in the e6 pawn that's a
lot to have in this position there goes
that man nvl is really trying to put his
foot
well I won't finish that it is a
put down let's just say down on the guy
this is um this is looking pretty good
well as we came into our show we were
saying how big and how crucial is a game
I felt it was very crucial and Maurice
was thinking that
yeah it's extremely important that MVL
wins but it doesn't mean that the
tournament's over and that neppo has got
the tournament in the back kind of thing
and I was thinking like yeah maybe
certainly play like it yeah because he
just going forward he's playing really
nice chess in my opinion this is the
kind of chess I want to see from a
candidate it's you gotta get it you got
to go get it yes I'll add also a very
important point is a win against nip oh
yes what's him in the lead for right it
doesn't tie them he's in the lead
because the tie breaks are in his favor
because the first tie break if they end
up tied at the very end of the
tournament the first tie break is your
head-to-head matchup so he will have won
that game which means when he sees neppo
in round 14 right if ya stay to forum
you'll see we're definitely the last
round
they'll be if they're tied never will
have to win that game in order to get
the tournament he'll get the white
pieces for sure but you will have to win
so that's how big it is a win right now
puts Maxime in the lead despite the tied
score just referring back to the exact
position on the board one of the things
that that the amateur players really
have to understand that white plays the
move h4 h5 purposely for the strategic
idea of playing f4 f5 if you didn't have
your pawn on h5 then a move like f4 in a
French will be met by g6 after and you
just kind of stop stop or you know
Stinney white from playing the the
desirable f4 f5 but now with the pawn on
h5 something that he committed to really
earlier like right out of the opening
you know you're set up for the f4 fi
break now here one of the things that
particularly stands out is obviously the
fact that blacks King is terrible
that's terrible but also the night on d7
the night of the sound it's usually a
huge problem for the French right what
actually gives up Tempe sometimes of the
nights ends up on v7 or not somewhere
else
exactly now you could put the night that
is currently on d7 on the ease of it you
could see a lot more harmonious kind of
thing happening in blacks position
because then he could play King d7 and
you know he's stopping f4 f5 I see
really severe problems and in fact I see
problems so severe I might have almost
suggested to have played the move Knight
b8 to c6 so that the king could actually
end up on d7 right now I just I really
like what MBL is done and definitely I
see Yann on the back foot here yeah it's
almost a panic mode for the black pieces
right once that five cats and you will
got made it yeah the engine is even
suggesting ninety-seven absolutely like
you just play nice ease sakes they have
played at four and now go back right and
and stop this really tremendous move you
just lost a lot of time playing that
line I will say the only - in that case
- the move the move f4 is that the
knight doesn't exactly get to f4 itself
in some of the lines we were looking at
but yeah sir as you point now it's
possible to play very freely with this
move g4 what's the guy gonna do to open
up your Kings side anyway will he be
desperate and play a five at some point
I think here I mean you might have to
just let you go and take on pissant in
that position and hope that he's gonna
get some counter play after Knight takes
which by the way the e4 square does
become a little compromised little a
point there for him Knight takes here
with the night trying to get to that
Square and hitting the pawn this this
could play into blacks hands more so I
would rather this position than the one
who other one sure at least so that's
something that Maxime will have to pay
attention to just how he avoids breaks
by black so the f4 square was conceded
by placing upon on that square we we
have to at least say that so
ninety-seven looks like maybe the best
defensive move at the moment it doesn't
solve the problem of that rook on h8
however and I think black black will
have to deal with white going on the
Queen side again
I have a simple question sure you
sacrifice an exchange once yeah I not
again can I just go at five direct Lois
they're just asking a little bit too
much did you say a simple oh what an
interesting idea well the idea was that
we were sacrifice it in exchange for you
know getting our Bishop into play here
the exchange sacrifice may not as as
beautifully but who's dropping and
dropping the a pawn yeah yeah and I
don't like that I'm trading off my
everybody every rook comes on now unless
a six is bringing home some really good
look at no it just feels like I ran out
of steam yeah but okay inspired but
probably not necessary I said let me
interrupt us we usually don't take phone
calls this early in the show but we have
a fan from Nepal and well let's let him
hear what he has to say
alright does your name and your wishes
hello hi hi hi alejandro high and high
body is pleased talking to you and happy
birthday yes I didn't have any question
to us I just want to thank you thank all
of you gentlemen but it lovely community
it
these are watching you a lot to learn
from you and the way you explain so that
a beginner like me can understand it's
really really nice caught a few from you
and and what what can I say about you
you you are always very smiling cheerful
it lovely to watch what you unhappy but
the I really don't have a question to
ask
I just want to convey my best wishes to
you thank you so much yay yesterday was
so disturbing I wanted to use my newly
minted senior discount card you go out
and party and you know like get get my
10% off of whatever it was disappointing
I couldn't use my new senior card but
thank you very much of the caller
the senior car doesn't go away good good
that's very very important
yeah I got a lot of the birthday wishes
so that was very very nice thank you
[Music]
thank you both to fabbi and to a niche
who sent me happy birthday wishes as
well dude you've got to be concentrating
on the tournament yeah
don't be sending me happy birthday
wishes that's nice there you have Bryan
Adams on our production staff I think
this is our chess and the reddit website
right so everybody I do browse that
pretty often I can't think of any but
anything cooler than hanging out with
yasser having some wine to hear him tell
some chest story not to say that it's
pretty cool but he's careful because he
might drink you under the table smokes
do you remember where there was the
where this was from Maurice this looks
like could it have been like a world
like a deep I be M oh this is this is
maybe Kasparov Anand at the World Trade
Center yeah we got a devil sword
look at the background too right I mean
we could be on the 110 floor of the
World Trade Center how do you control
those pieces the other like a remote or
do you we called that old-school the
collar and to all our fans that are
awake in Asia I know that we have plenty
of them world champion Judas tuning in
yes let's keep going with the games we
do have a couple that we haven't seen
right so maybe I can direct your
attention to the Anish game see what's
going on in that one
okay this came from an English and as
usual
never we're talking about Alexander
Grisha he does get his long thinks in
the opening this is actually an unusual
move Knight f3 it's become quite popular
since thing there and has been using in
with white and fabric has been using it
with black and despite the fact that
never have clashed in this particular
position it's like they indirectly clash
Tingler and kept having new ideas with
wider favi cat having new ideas right
echoes of an alle kind but also a
Sicilian reversed and you can recapture
for the Queen very important to disrupt
the flow from white if you recapture
with the pawn white often just gets an
easy game with d3 Bishop g2 and so on
the Queen takes d5 is the most
disruptive and now blacks King is just
hanging in the center you have a fork
which is also a bit of a target and
imagine that white wants to really
pressure it there's not an easy
comfortable way to develop it you see
that Knight coming to the rim on a6 and
partially that's because it allows the
knight to come to c5 but also if I need
to the bishop can jump to f5 and if and
this pawn on e4 before having to move
the knight again support soon I don't
want to step on the 7 square you keep
the bishop open okay so this looks like
some heavy duty
theoretical battle going on now castles
why does thinking okay I'm ready to go
maybe to d4 and take advantage of the
open e file they should be seven all
very logical there's been a very nice
flow to the game here we've been told
there's a novelty of the game I can
imagine that d4 in the past something of
this nature before gotta be right
because everything's so very logical and
we can imagine that the Queen will go to
h5 in a number of variations
obviously this Bishop on g2 is very good
though I was about to say we couldn't
even maybe start with Queen Age it
wouldn't be in blacks favor to try to
force the trade but that did not happen
93
this doesn't really change the character
position in my opinion the nitrous
well-placed on e3 and it's challenging
black to find a move a little bit you
could Castle and just say whatever right
and this is where Bishop went into a
thirty minute thing but that's the other
option because you have other things but
let me stop you right there we have
breaking news from the key matchup
absolutely in this position really
interesting nepo did find a knight back
to e7 he said I've got to do it I've got
to stop at five coming down the board so
much so that I have to root to be one
he also played f5 he said this move
cannot be played now this position is
really interesting because there's the
possibility of takes and takes and we
see White has not conceded that this II
Foursquare for black and black could say
well now if I can get my knight in to e4
maybe get a knight later to f5 and a
king here I'm stemming the tide it's not
so easy to break through now the engines
give f5 as a move here f5 what a move
the idea being as I mentioned earlier to
get the Knight to f4 that's gifting a
whole pawn for this position
don't forget this point on h5 is also
hanging in the position but the engine
wants to get to g6 to e5 maybe get a
Bishop to f4 plane for g4 and just break
through on this side a very dramatic
concept indeed I don't know that MV I
will be willing to just start tossing
pawns unless he sees that it's just
overwhelming because he had such a great
position to start it's the fact that you
have to start sacrificing pawns in order
to actually show that you have dynamic
play but not just be winning that's
going to be tricky to find I think and
so I expect more action to happen on
this side of the board
other than this trade this move f5 a
very contentious one if
neppo gets in king f7 and rook to b8 we
might not be saying he's so bad after
all
that seems like it's potentially tenable
as he can then just put all his
attention on this side so it seems to be
unless g4 is good to Dungey for doesn't
do it either how does how does mvl avoid
capturing on f6 right now thank you
yeah definitely Thank You Maurice once I
see f-five I know it's just so visual
the night coming to the e5 square and
then following it up with g4 it's so
tempting yes that part is so irrelevant
especially the part I for it's on the
way of your pieces it's not a very
precious pawn it's one of those pawns
that you're okay jealous I mean I've
seen this concept in the French pretty
often where you guys give up something
to be able to control e5 the fact that
the f1 is unusual yeah but it's pretty
cool
f5 do it okay not do it he played rugby
five right again I think the idea is
right alejandra what you're saying it's
something that's difficult it's
something something that you we will
have seen especially as a player with
the French from the black side right
because you're defending this position a
lot so you've seen enough players with
the white try to break down your
position if you're white as nvl you
don't see it that much all your
instincts maybe you've seen the idea but
all your instincts don't scream this
idea because you don't see this position
that much in your practice nobody's
playing you the French too much you even
though he's French by the way maybe
they're avoiding and just because of the
opening but I think more so is the
momentum of the position I've got the B
file you've got nothing to do you just
played 96-97 why should I do anything
special I'm just gonna beat you up on
this side of the board I'll have all the
advantages my [ __ ] is gonna come back
to this diagonal I should be ahead so
now let me just press let me press
before your King comes in the game now
the fact that this guy can play King f7
to me and bring the rook in the now I
feel like it's giddyup time it's like
hurry up before he gets anything going
because otherwise he's gonna argue that
he's had this time that is he worse here
guys it looks still looks like White's
ahead but I'd love to have my bishop
already here and my Knights someplace
that's what he's doing just play Queen
a6 then instantly and it looks pretty
bad for luck right it does it does but
let's continue the line king of a3 b3
let's saw move the I don't put on d6 are
about to attack me but I'm hitting this
alright so I'll go here okay so here's
where I was thinking that MV o would be
playing for a line like Bishop e7 and
for now that's important use me they
made all those moves - then throw this
in that looks right Lizzy threats
crusher that's a little more scrumptious
you wanted to sacrifice the exact rifice
the pawn with f5 right I see this pawn
sacrifice coming to g4 and I don't want
to trade off all the rooks if you take
twice on b5 I probably maintain one of
the rooks may be something like rook f1
that's right I'll take looks really
really strong there why maxime yeah and
it looks very logical also because Nepos
plan of king f7 rule HPA this is what he
wants to do yes if he doesn't do this I
think the only other plan might be to
play something like g6 but at this point
it's very counterintuitive right yeah no
I mean black just lost so much time
playing Knight c67 and rook h8 it just
seems like okay maybe F for itself block
kind of thing but once you see g4 and f5
important game
let's keep and so so what happened was
it was actually kind of funny right here
is where Sasha went into one of his
patented think tanks of course after 30
minutes of you know due diligence you
know he played h5 and he said okay I'm
going after your king and he said come
on my king safe enough you're not going
after my king and then it's funny how
just one move changes the character of
the position before h5 s on the board
and you played d4 you kind of took on d3
and instantly without hesitation took
with the Queen right above once upon us
on h5 kind of withheld hesitation you
take with the pawn because you see that
King on e8 is not gonna Castle therefore
it's in the center therefore when they
work on you want it's kind of a thought
process that happens for us kind of
naturally right but it's funny how just
one little detail of the position the
pawn being on h5 versus being on h7 I
see this and I thinking to myself well
if I take with the Queen maybe you play
h4 and you put your Queen over on
age five and checkmate me down the
h-file so I'll take with the pawns that
you can't go h5 exactly the Queen I
don't the other hand I'm actually eyeing
rook e1 maybe slide five business your
Kings on the 8th after all and that's a
big tempo against the Queen on e5 this
is a very nice little maneuver there by
Grisha Queen d4 getting his queen out of
the way and this wasn't what I mean she
had in mind
92 I mean and queen g4 and I think the
worst is over for for black after you
think this was yeah I think because that
night on c2 went to e3 and kind of came
back if there was already a bishop on f4
and then the night went to e3 I think it
would be much different and we quickly
reached this current position it's
certainly imbalanced it might be equal
but how do we even start assessing this
position there's a weakness on d4
question is yes well d5 really bother
black and is it actually a threat I
think that that's what it really boils
down to
after all that is a king on CA I get
Rick c1 and d5 I can see a niche who by
the way boy talk about having to win
than yourself
thank you yeah just to give you to be
gifted a point like that and here's
their lifetime score pretty balanced a
little bit surprised by anisha's success
he actually has a plus corner it gets
Rick I would have imagined the veteran
the wily veteran that Bishop is might
have caught anisha's a young man but
you're not so surprised about the 11
drop not surprised by the 11 draws but
that's you know one okay so here what
I'm thinking is if Y can get in the move
d5 and I mean let's just put one move on
the board to see what might have a very
logical exactly the knight is heading
the bishop on g4 which means that I want
to retreat it exactly I like the bishops
and but more importantly I'm trying to
stop d4 d5 are you playing rook c1 he
playing Bishop c70 playing what do you
think you want is a one tempo too slow
right
yet your Knight to d5 and unless I have
something concrete here I'll blockade
yeah
Bishop on e5 is now getting targeted I
definitely don't want to trade too many
pieces suddenly for myself a weakness
may be playing for b4 b5 with a 3 B 4 B
5 a little too slow it's law it
definitely will jump into mine yeah yeah
if you could get the pawn magically to
b5 quite quickly that but a3 does feel
slow I agree with you wholeheartedly
there well none of this works for white
I will add some important start thinking
do I go d5 does it actually work like
immediately yeah but it just feels like
I'm giving up a pawn you can just think
everything well at the end of their day
a c1 there is a rook c1 site oops sorry
I went the one like but as we do figure
out all these trades let's go to Maurice
and our marquee matchup yes and nvl did
find this move after Queen a6 Bishop to
c1 and the bishop to a3 and it is clear
he's threatening Bishop takes East 7
with a g4 idea on top if white if black
doesn't pay attention so I decided to
try and move I said could I defend this
with g6 out 100 years suggested this
move not in this exact position
necessarily and I said ok takes takes I
want you to take I get my rookie to the
game and things are not so bad are they
maybe I'm fighting here the engine set
up wake up Maurice we're buying g4
immediately cracking the position open
and now if ruk to g8 a simple and
conking f2 getting out of the way and
now it's time for smashing taking on the
square taking on at 5
what about visual what a way to crack a
pawn structure to pieces this is just
devastating and neppo is stuck right now
after Bishop 83 you saw him make this
maneuver after Bishop c1 King of 7 I
think now the Cubs are clear these look
at he's going there's a straight threat
to simply crash through my position boy
he is in serious trouble it's no
surprise all the temple he lost playing
rook ga
back to h8 king de fa king - he ate nine
to c6 Knight to e7
that's three moves lost as far as my
count hey nvl say you can't do that
against me
I'm sorry I'm just gonna crack your
position open that waste of time is not
gonna work if you're trying to win this
tournament Wow big development well
let's take a look there's one game we
haven't looked at at all and yes I'll
state it is the only ran against
Kirilenko we'll go briefly it is not the
most important again unfortunately for
both of these players they are wallowing
in a shared last there was a move Queen
a5 and I thought that from Kiril this
was quite a challenge
so you just played you'd play Queen a
for attacking my pawn yeah go ahead
you know finish your threat he didn't
take the pawn on e7 a fight before and
now I'll take the pawn on a 7 intriguing
idea by adding glare in 94 and we're up
to date with the players by the way
Knight c3 what's going on in this game
only on drew it feels pretty unbalanced
but it is already taking on b6 yes okay
blacks down a pawn correct
but he's 93 tricks and I can at least
get my palm back I can always play with
93 and take they're taking on c4 or take
on e2 check and by the way that rook on
f8 is ready to giddyup and get into the
game my first impression is the White
House to be careful there are so many
tricks in blacks position definitely I'm
I'm looking at the bishop on h3 the
Queen on b6 hitting the pawn on e6 and
the only way I justify that as 94 is
that pawn on e6 because I can stop my
rook it opens up my queen we're gonna
have some tactical difficulties once you
take this pawn
okay but again I am
material materialist so let's just see
but here are you taking this is actually
I mean under a different set of
circumstances this would be a very
intriguing situation not to D to rook on
D 1 to e 1 a defending the pawn on each
other you can take on c4 I don't see an
actual problem I think you must take on
c4 idea maybe to post up with a bishop
on d5 but must but well I mean come on
your pawn down and you you gotta get I
mean there might even just be an a3 move
to undermine this night well maybe yeah
but the initiative actually if I can
just play e5 e4 I was wondering if you
actually run into trouble b5 e4
Wow my goodness okay it's maybe a little
bit too much Wow but I thought if I take
with a knight I go before I go III okay
okay I can see that you that the free
day is really charged or battery you're
ready to rock and roll and go on the
attack
to begin with but this would be a great
game if these Pete players would be
really tied for first I disagree game
the game that is for first place is
actually a great game - Maurice yes and
I'm following the thematic I said I'm
desperate to defend for black here I'm
just trying to figure out for nip oh so
I tried another idea after g4 rook a
fade I get it he keeps swinging pieces
back and forth I do one and put it back
why not keep up the party the problem
here is there a couple of moves that are
devastating we can start with rook takes
actually let's just do night g3 right
ignoring the fact that this is hanging
then take and Knight b6 and now Queen 87
and everybody's coming in to party yes
I'm trying to hold my position together
please no you're not we don't care we're
just coming straight at you to break the
position open if you take one aim for F
day c6 don't take with the Queen and let
the rook crash in that's gonna be death
as everything is gonna scream I'll just
show it to you so you see how bad it is
this King has to go backwards well
you're just gonna get killed obviously
this is
is too horrible for words so you can't
let him crash through after f takes c6
but king takes it's not possible either
as the other side of the board comes
into play as well as your queen is
hanging on a6 to this skewer I mean it's
just blah just aim shoot kill like what
the heck it's just devastating this idea
takes takes Queen we've been talking
about Queen eight something for a while
and this crashing through his position
split White's king is just laughing all
the pawns have moved forward but it
doesn't matter its King is just sitting
pretty and safe this is an overwhelming
advantage just a crushing attack and
it's playing itself here and that is why
neppo has not moved he's sitting here
looking at his position that's already a
story when neckla doesn't move
he's in trouble he's at 27 minutes with
13 moves that's not so much of a problem
the problem is how do you stop Bishop
takes a 7 and G for the threat is so
direct he's looking probably everywhere
to see how can I slow this down but f5
it doesn't have the same protection this
pawn we're just back on the h7 square
you maybe could play g6 who different
story but with this formation you cannot
hold this one Quan together and this
break g4 is hanging over his head this
is busted I can't tell you how bad that
night on d7 looks like it's just not a
terrible not doing anything in the game
by the way we'd like that this time in
the broadcast to invite our viewers to
give us a call and ask us any questions
you would like about the 20/20
candidates and there's the number on
your screen to to give a skull three one
four three six one five four six five
we'll be here waiting for your call ask
us any questions about chess sure about
the candidates meanwhile let's take a
look at the games let's update the Fabi
game of course that's again this was a
game between two players on the 50%
score when we left it right about these
parts we saw this move Knight g5 we
thought that witnessed move Knight g5
White might be getting a little bit of a
nibble thanks to the move c4 that was
not fab ease approach he actually played
the move Bishop g5 a move we really
didn't pay that much attention to then
King King f7
it protects an f6 and it basically says
to white okay go ahead and do your worst
and 93 a retreating move but it does
prepare Knight f5 so okay it does have
its own series of ideas maybe on a good
day pawn on HSN surprising thing after
c4 my black encouraging you to take on
aged 75 I didn't do so it seems like
black had probably more than one way to
deal with this okay go ahead and share
that because there's the vlog scared of
g6 but I don't know if it'll work well
yeah this was the question right okay if
I take on g6 the King could end up you
know way out here on a limb but maybe if
you're not mated it's kind of you are a
piece off your king like should be okay
it's kind of hard to mate with two rooks
exactly it's not the most coordinated
attacking forces I've seen either an
intriguing line if Abby said look I
trust you yeah I trust you I'm going to
just drop back with my bishop oh by the
way maybe but a quick break Maurice
breaking news well as we anticipated the
hammer has in fact landed and after rook
to H rook H to b8 bishops a c7 King
takes played briskly by both players and
here's the move g4 on the board if MBL
wins this game in style it will be one
of his masterpieces to be so proud of
this game and especially if it's the one
that catapults him to challenging Magnus
Carlsen for the title this one is just a
massive blow g4 the one break that white
has White has no more pawn break so it's
no surprise that he sees g4 and says
clearly the only pawn break that white
has how else are you going to stream
into the position but you don't need
anymore because g4 is just such a
massive move then I can go to g3 you
cannot sustain this square f5 his
position is collapsing is Nepos and he's
at 26 minutes he's got enough time but
it's not looking like it's gonna matter
position just looks like completely
busted everything in wise favor now
we'll see can he come up with a miracle
defense and we do have other breaking
news well this is actually yesterday's
during the free day the pide did
announce defeated yeah a federation in
terms of just nation announced that the
chess olympian which is probably the
biggest and most important was the event
that we feed a organizes a each every
two years it's like a hundred and eighty
nations from all over the world meet for
their biannual Olympiad and it has been
postponed as been rescheduled for the
summer of 2021 similar to the problems
in tokyo wow that's big news for us i
know that a lot of people look forward
to the Olympia exactly I know I do I
know me too I played in ten Olympiads
and I just loved all of them they were
all very different that for me it was
well sorry to borrow the motto gen zoom
assumed as one family and the idea of
going and meeting all of these teams
from countries all over the world and
what's really cool is on the opening and
closing ceremonies a lot of the teams
wear their national outfits and it's
just so cool it really is great it's a
great event a great party it's a great
chess festival it's like and well we're
gonna have to wait one more year to see
it it this year it'll be in Moscow well
supposed to be Moscow hopefully next
year there are no problems hosting it
there exactly and again we're just
taking a look at this fabulous
Oh Marie sorry well some excitement at
this moment and I echo the Olympiad is
just simply a wonderful event bringing
players from everywhere around the world
together you you see it as the
of the people who have been reading
about the heroes the famous players the
Fabiano's of the world and the NV ELLs
the nepos you know your fans and you see
you see them in the magazines and then
you get to represent your country
wherever you are larger small country
you get to go to this event represent
your country and meet your great chess
heroes in mass not one or two at a
tournament where maybe there's only ten
of them there 4050 the top 50 players in
the world basically are there at the
event representing all these nations so
great event it'll be back folks it's
it's postponed not canceled so it will
be back in the meantime this position
this one is huge right now after the
move a three a quiet move allowing the
move Knight takes eetu and takes on f3
allowing this possibility the engines
give this is better for black despite
the fact that he might be going down
something here well he's got the two
passports but there's a rook hanging in
this position a bishop on f3 no question
about it
white looks like he's in dire straits in
a position like this one but he did like
a three on purpose allowing this line so
what is it starting here that in this
position he decided he could play this
move I know the pawns hanging but
there's another one that seems more
crucial in e2 bingler in not pleasing
his fans in this game can he go down to
the bottom seed we're talking the bottom
seed of the event with white he be
playing that would just be disastrous
it's bad enough but that would just
completely tumble him into the cellar
unimaginable that such a solid players
dangler in who had the greatest year of
his career 2019 should start with three
losses and in trouble we have a caller
from Canada yes please give us your name
and your question as we keep an eye on
the other games
my name is from Windsor Canada our first
party of Alejandro Maurice in Gaza and
you're 30 as well yes and thank you for
become very on the pcl with the search
process is a pleasure to hear you there
so my question was we see we saw never
played the French at it there are
usually an open with we see in pop you
know popular tournament so I was
wondering if you guys had stories about
other players who played different or
avi or other opening and pop their
plates all right well thank you very
much for the question let me jump right
in there
there have been numbers of players who
do playoff beat for me in Thessaly the
von Schaack is one of those players who
literally when you sit down the board
you play e4 don't be surprised if he
hits you with an alkyne or a friend or a
Scandinavian or something else and I do
remember actually back in New York with
Maurice in 1995 as far off Vishy Anand a
Scandinavian appearing not once but
twice by Vichy for d5 like that was
really really a big surprise even as the
one that you remember I was thinking
about the other example it was Gary with
black who's playing the dragon I mean
the dragon who saw the dragon was coming
and it turned out to be a brilliant
brilliant
yeah absolutely great and the first game
you got a draw to a nice way to so yeah
it isn't it is surprising and upsetting
and I remember also a wonderful book I
strongly recommend the book it was my
life in games by Michael tall and tall
was playing in this big in Interzone
tournament and he asked a second well
who do I play tomorrow and ii said you
play bent Larsen and what color am i oh
you will be white Misha
and what will I play said Misha efore
okay and what will he play said Misha I
don't know because with Larson you had
no idea it's not
big open tournament and you face Vasily
Avanti
right because it just go for a walk yeah
there's no point in preparing at all who
do you think of these candidates players
as a player who could pull off something
some really unusual opening and take
somebody completely out of their prep
who is the most likely to do none of
these are players that really stray too
far from their preparation they
sometimes incorporate new ideas okay but
if you can succeed go down the list
they're actually pretty solidly stuck to
their opening and ble I've been playing
me for the nightmare group felt maybe
the worst case and we're all in anyways
yeah you know he's fighting the French
again but it was something that he used
to use not this variation specifically
but it was part of his repertoire he
kind of went down a bit with the
popularity of the French because French
is currently considered to be suffering
as we can see Grichuk maybe for a perk
Chris Chuck no no I mean Greece replaced
Berlin 95% of the time nowadays well how
place Petrov pretty much exclusively
pretty solidly on e45 player and
although he does put a dabble in the
Sicilian a little bit Sicilian less and
less okay unfortunately for the world of
chess because it was so young he really
don't know he's kind of a wild card in
many ways not just because he was the
wild kind of the organizers and dilling
ding is pretty fixed player how do these
players are all pretty fixed he goes
down a couple of notches and you bring
somebody like Robert then you're gonna
there is a guy some new ideas Maurice
how is MVL doing he's doing fine this
position rook takes me 580 HP five rook
takes and we've seen this line before at
five is gonna drop and he has captured
on at five the breakthrough has indeed
occurred a knight will land on g3 at
some point this pawn is going to go no
matter what you do that's that's
dropping somehow or he'll capture and
it'll be these pawns that will be
marching down the board this King is
much safer maybe even hide on ether
if it needs to this King though even
though it looks like he could get back
home to g8 looks like it's not going to
happen too much is going to be going on
in the center of the board so we're
waiting for a move here we're also
waiting for a move in this game between
ding Lorraine and Alex & Co and we
thought that you know looks like Keira
could just play Knight takes eetu and go
for the bishop takes f3 line but it
looks like he's been thinking for I
think 12 minutes okay on this position
15 now 15 since I've been talking this
seven minutes left to make 14 moves it's
not like you have some nice clear
crystal clear waters ahead as long I
know exactly what I'm supposed to do
here I'm just gonna do this there's this
position clarifies itself this is still
murky and he sees his e6 pawn no doubt
after this Knight takes a to capture he
sees that's gonna drop he thinks maybe
this might drop is he thinking that one
too it doesn't look bad for him it's
easy for us to say we're not worried
sitting at the board trying to survive
our survive here but he has been
thinking down to seven minutes guys
14 I think actually he hasn't made his
26 move yet so a lot of most to go ding
Lauren might not be dead just yet given
that his opponent is in a severe time
pressure alright thank you for that
isn't that even if I was saying Co does
find all these movie was just worse
right yeah well Queen g5j gave
Blackbeard we do have a phone color
machine from Michigan so let's go right
into it please give us your name and
your question yeah my name is Mark and I
was wondering I know
Neville has a good score against Magnus
I know five years pretty good scores
beau but I'm wondering to what extent
can a clash of styles affect a match in
a game of complete information well and
it's one of the one of the great
conundrums of the chess world that it
very very often happens that you get
three world-class players and player a
consistently defeats player B and player
B come
sistent Lee defeats player C and player
see consistently defeats player a so
they're somehow stylistically you can
get that situation where one player
dominates another player and yet
mathematically these results are not
supposed to happen their outlying
results but they do happen and yet I do
have I think Vichy explaining it very
well in his book he said when such a
thing happens it just means that in
certain positions in certain aspects of
the game your opponent has a better
understanding than you do and you need
to sit down and figure out why is he
better at me than me at these kind of
positions dispositions I'm losing these
positions I'm losing clearly I'm being
steered into the kind of things where I
have a bad score against you
stylistically this is not working for me
how can I remedy it either by strafing
away from it the way that Magnus used to
do he straight away from complications
from opening preparations when he was a
younger player or by just getting better
at it
which also something Magnus did nowadays
complicated game Magnus says yum-yum
that's give me the attack right but it's
certainly important now to clarify what
the caller was resisting asking I gave a
perfect information what is that that
means that you can see your opponent's
hands past yeah yeah for example game
like poker is a game of incomplete
information right yes guessing you're
trying to deduce by logic water your
opponent has but you don't actually know
here you don't know what your opponent's
plants are but you see his moves on the
boards called a game of perfect
information exactly and they are they're
actually very interesting game theory
differences between those types of games
and the ones where you don't actually
know what your opponent is doing and for
example another game like that would be
the game of go right very similar but
also very very complicated game you can
see what your opponent's moves are and
you can guess what their strategy might
be but you can't be certain how deep the
game can go I just wanted to jump right
back to the fabbi game because we never
finished
we have a million moves on that I know
we never got a chance to really finish
where where the game stop after the move
see Ford there was no Bishop age seven
ideas retreat the bishop just retreated
on looks like a very decent move and
here I really like this move by a be a
four why because well okay I'm not a big
fan of trading I just like the idea of
getting off the back ranked mate babbys
surprised me he actually captured I
personally I would have rather kept that
tension maybe it's not a big deal Knight
f5 attack the bishop on e7 the bishop on
e7 moved and we I think we have some
more we have a lot more moves okay Wow
sorry this let's just go back I mean
they really went fast times are
perfectly fight from both for both got
three things takes take so everything
came off the board I mean it was it was
just a vacuum that just occurred unless
I'm losing c4 this looks extremely dry
well I can imagine one way you
potentially could lose c4 black does
have to defend against this threat
they're the desirable rugby 7
unfortunately has a drawback at the b7
square is protected like you have to
find a move here for black right because
96 Knight takes e4 might just be well
it's two extra passed pawns I don't and
if I try to for example get out of that
first of all the bishop on g5 while it's
hanging at the moment I could
any-any move with the night by the way
will protect the deficient hmm I don't
know maybe it's just time to go on the
counter-attack with I like pawns
it does feel there's too little material
left and I was a color bishop so many
times that element also yeah it feels
really dry to me it feels like it okay
Maurice jump jump in you've got a game
that also we haven't paid enough
attention to well it's time to pay
attention to it now
as absolute Hoover the vacuum somebody
vacuum lean a person to show in and just
start vacuum everything off but take a
look I want you guys at the end of this
to evaluate this position that's a hint
that be careful how you judge and look
at this d5 what's the one square you
cannot push up on five things on that
square that's not going to happen except
it did and now watch at the massive
exodus of pieces as the trades happened
absolutely incredible rook c1 check King
d7 rook c7 and all these moves are
played I blitz speed by the way by Grizz
shook and Aneesh and rook takes b7 it
looks like anis said hey I sacked a pawn
I came down crashed it on the seventh
I took the pawn back on b7 I'm about to
take your pawn on a seven this is sweet
Hawking and you blame me for play just
like this and bris shook instantly after
all that dropped down look - c8 saying
you can have this pawn on a7 if you like
I'm the one with all the activity if you
take I'm gonna play the move rook to c2
I'm hitting a pawn if you defend it I'm
gonna play Bishop c5 I'm into your F
pawn give me that guy back if you try to
defend I'm gonna play d4 I've got the
King the active King I've got the active
rook I've got the bishop I've got a
passed pawn
guess who's actually winning after your
sweet little combination with d5 it is
black who is better here black who was
playing for this move rook c8 is going
to freeze and it has frozen giri in his
tracks after forcing the line at the end
at this point
rook c8 the the tail end of the
combination is poisonous guys what an
amazing piece of calculation bye-bye
Grizz joke to allow this line and know
that at the end he's the one who's gonna
be better that's all it's not just a cat
collation it's judgement it's a
difficult thing to grab a position to
sauce complex in the middle game room
take off all of the pieces and say it's
the end game how is it because initially
that real combi seven I think how many
of us would have fallen for that you
he loved that active room worst-case
scenario equal I would have never
thought white is worse in that position
but you put it on the board and I'm
starting to think yeah I think one would
rather be anywhere else and suddenly it
starts to dawn on you that your
positions not very good
exactly time to play Bishop III and
maybe seize the draw we have another
color this one from New York yes hello
caller and welcome to our show your name
and question please
sometimes to play while like when he was
his rook and you think that he'd give
her a hard time to Magnus then let's say
Fabian was more solid what do you think
he'd blow up because he played crazy and
wind up losing and sometimes I think
that Magnus will be playing wild horse
so I'd have a better chance Thank You
Charlie for the question because count
somehow that kind of goes hand in glove
with the information right the the
players how they match up against each
other I think we're gonna be having this
conversation quite a bit as we get
closer to the end of the tournament
breaks up the party but briefly how in
your view would they match up in a world
championship
we know neppo has a huge score dangerous
player mm-hmm an extremely dangerous
knockout player I mean yeah extremely
that's the guy you hate playing under
knockout we're a 2-2 game match your
game match up so fast so rapid drop it's
so strong you can't predict his moves
right and in a class 12 game World
Championship
match I mean he's not suited it's not
suited for it that's not his type of
chest okay he could change you would
have to plenty of time to prepare but if
you'd ask me who is a great match player
I don't immediately think of Nepal
Miyagi no I would even think about
Aneesh as being a match player that
maybe Magnus wouldn't be so happy jump
right in here man
Maurice how do you think Knepper would
do in a 12 game match with Magnus of
course I think you guys nailed it I
think you guys nailed it he would have
to sort of just get the bugs out of his
game when you're playing in some Magnus
Carlsen you better not have hiccups he
Magnus doesn't mess around he finds her
weaknesses he pressures he pressures he
finds a weakness and then he just pounds
you and I just don't see they have to I
don't see the refinement level of his
game he's a bit wild he's almost like
tall in that respect but Magnus we're
talking about I just don't see him
ideally suited although he has a plus
for Magnus first time so we can argue
yeah whatever whatever I got the plus
score what are you talking about I think
just those a little bit of uneven
moments in his game but who knows you
might catch a streak on Magnus hit
Magnus a couple of games and then Magnus
is potentially really I don't see it
though I do believe that guys like Fabi
of course is proven in Geary I thought
was really a great point you made there
yeah so Gary's super solid I don't think
the world really wants to see that match
between Gary and although the other ones
might of Magnus Magnusson Magnus versus
Geary sounds too solid maybe another
12th draw is taking place because
because gear is just so solid but I
think this gentleman
Maxine var Selig Rob and Magnus what are
we guaranteed some night orcs and some
grin fellows right we will be guaranteed
some sharp play and you know how
stubborn MVL is he said I'm gonna fix by
now every time I'm gonna play these
sharp openings that would be fun I don't
know if would work out in his favor
given that his grunt phil has been under
heavy pressure from the players lately
but
certainly would be fun by the way we
just want to update this this is the big
dog matchup in this round after all and
night g3 no I don't want to take your
pawn and allow maybe some potential
Queen exchange offers nothing I don't
need to I'm taking that with cheque and
Queen b6 was played in the position
Queen b6 and now he can capture I'm not
sure they made any moves as yet no MVL
is sitting on that position as he can
capture on f5 and there's no way he was
a queen exchange here your king is too
vulnerable these pawns his knight he's
not worried about his own King although
he won't have to pay attention of this
Queen does show up and start to do some
things but a knight here looks so sweet
nights gonna be able to protect the King
against my pets this night is very
passive as we pointed out and there's
this past pawn but there's this one as
well so we know black is in deep trouble
here but certainly nvl has to take take
some technical corners that he has to
deal with this game though rook c8 Gary
didn't think much at all he took here
and allowed rook to c2 and now we see
the move Bishop to e3 right late you're
not allowed on this diagonal forget
about that I can give you my pawn back
so we would anticipate a move like rook
takes although the engines giving bishop
to f6 as better to prepare d4 well that
looks pretty direct
so now Chris Turk has slowed down again
in 16 minutes to make 12 moves he got a
bunch of moves in but it still didn't
matter because he spent so much time on
h5 and other moves but this one is
absolutely still pretty interesting now
these are players at 50% yeah we need to
get those victories mvl has taken on a
fight with the knight which also looked
pretty tempting with well I was about to
say in that game I like the pawn
sacrifice parachute the activity and I
think he should just continue with it by
the way with Bishop f6 I pulled up the
game of dangler and I just go here I
really might finish
yeah I was gonna say that you know for
pawn and again we you know we're talking
about this active King it's all about
this passer you play d5 and that active
King can really take take part I don't
see any issues here for black black I
don't think I think blacks playing for
the win yeah yeah exactly and so I see
this as incredible judgment by one into
the end game right that being inside of
your Geary front I would have be too
worried yet it doesn't feel like white
should have this under control something
to a draw than it is to a black victory
right rook a four and maybe King f1 and
just get ready to kind of like Corral
the pond right before it becomes really
to get too dangerous but there will be a
defensive task yeah again yes sir one I
wouldn't be on again I really do want to
I mean are we completely convinced that
you know Yan is toast here I mean it
just it does feel like you know it is
MBL's game I didn't want to put it on a
- oh pardon me let's say here because
Queen she too might be surprisingly
difficult to meet I like it I like it I
like the flexibility I just don't want
to I just don't want to fall victim so
sad for the old double attack with a oh
but I thought that on a good day if I
could go like Queen a3 check somehow in
concert with this Knight and Maurice
even mentioned that you could not maybe
even waddle your king up to e3 and
somehow you're you're avoiding a lot of
perps I really think whites for choice I
just didn't know how big it is what do
you mean you said all the reasons why it
is well be killing me because this Queen
B Wan counterplay there is still as you
may find a
I was about to ask you for a
recommendation
the thing is I'm one move away from just
making all my dreams come true the King
on anywhere on the second rank so that I
can play queen attacking g7 whether it
is a 3e 7 or 3G one it doesn't matter
once I'm in attacking this pawn it just
feels kind of crushing like avatar than
H do personally okay so H to personal
choice but and you're thinking that you
you've escaped yes this check and now
you're eyeballing like let me just put a
move on the board
what can I move kind of move your
eyeballing in g1 how to get to this guy
back what you want let's crushing you
still have a check on b2 but I can now
hide on h1 aha and we'll checkmate you I
don't doubt it
okay so there are issues definitely free
on our tournament leader is he's really
being challenged yes and it does look
really bad well be careful guys what was
your move
we went King h2 or so I was just
throwing the move on the board just to
name somebody h2 right here the move is
being given his Queen b3 after King H
King H because because not between c2
again again okay but the thing is what's
kind of deceptive about the position
actually yes please is uh and and you
have to note it what do we have we have
a queen or an eighth or queen anyone's
the obvious move queen a3 looks strong
the idea bringing the Queen on this line
also look strong but the idea of the
idea that's the most fundamental in this
position that actually crashes through
the most efficiently mm-hmm is 93 okay
mix the sauce yeah that's the one that's
the guy all this is is fluff and tactics
and maybe I'll make to you somehow and
all that but but if I go after this
thing right here you are
all kinds of conniptions and twist and
turn you the things you have to do to
try to defend this pawn because the
knight will go to e3 a queen can later
go to a5 the king will simply march up
and say it my pawns are protecting me I
can end up on f3 with my knight on e3
that'll be more than enough Mike Weir
will always be threatening things and
then at some point f5 is gonna come and
a 6 is gonna come and your position is
just going to completely collapse
exactly so the real thing MBI likes to
do is consolidate he has found Queen a1
and he's on the board but this is the
move just drop back and ask black what
are your pluses I see your passport it's
going nowhere when my Queen it's here I
just consolidating everything and then I
just bum-rush you and you're gonna fall
apart and this is an easy easy win for
MDL as there is no real count to play
for for black if you don't let him play
some tricky pieces once he consolidates
that's Johnny ball game no it looks
crushing I was about to say before we
take a break I just like to share one
quick story a couple of years ago Jordan
van forest was invited to play in the
Dutch championship because Sergey tivey
o'clock tibia cough declined his
invitation so this very young boy Jordan
van forest one of the lowest seeds was
invited into the Dutch Championship
which he convincingly won MBL get this
last minute last second invitation and
should he come through today oh that's
huge he would be in first place even
though it's a tie for first
head-to-head tiebreaker but we're gonna
take a short break on the other side of
this break we're gonna be back for more
action of round 7 in the 2020 candidates
[Music]
I want to thank you all for joining us
today for what is certainly an historic
moment we're privileged at ascension to
have a mission with a capital M and it's
who we are and it's about giving back to
the community it's a win for the
Champions Tour and our players it's a
win for the fans and the spectators be
surprised be intrigued be delighted the
world chess Hall of Fame in st. Louis is
nothing you'd expect and everything you
love three galleries highlight the
history culture and creativity behind
the game explore chess in ways you never
imagined it's a one-of-a-kind cultural
institution where rare artifacts and
world-class art play together the world
chess Hall of Fame mind art experience
st. Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of st. Louis
Slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015
SLU partner with the st. Louis chess
club to start a top-tier collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
team's inception slough obtain second
best university at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Russian superstar yonder pom the Chi has
now atop the leaderboard he was not
considered one of the top two favorites
in the event but his scintillating win
against an ish Gary followed by some
powerful blows I guess the two Chinese
players has now put him in a beautiful
situation moving forward will he be able
to close the deal
or will he collapse under the enormous
pressure we will see as this star tries
to bring home the possible challenges
title to his country no that was an
earlier recording to be sure and it
looks like it's be the answer is B we
said will he do well or will he collapse
well right now Queenie six-night g3
queen g4 has been played but this does
not seem like it's going to bring home
the bacon as a simple kidding g2 it's
something that we know famously when a
king and a knight are in this formation
it's almost impossible to deliver
perpetual check this is a very famous
setup the night next to the king
sometimes the knight is on the one side
I go to an f2 square as well as the same
thing it's very tricky to get that
diagonal where you're preparing this
King this one is the same if you take on
the square Queen takes on a 7 and this
Queen crashing through is much more
effective than this one this Knight is
not helping its King well he could play
this move King to a7 but it looks like
white can reset everything and now how
do you defend the position when the
Queen emerges into actually the engines
even giving this move seems a little
surprising to me after this
Oh the point is yes you're gonna get to
d6 by force I wanted to go to d6
immediately but Queen will the Queen
will get in you're just in trouble here
what to do as the Queen crashes into the
party D pawn drops C pawn will drop
everybody will drop and even if you
could play for it Queen d2 and get this
one these pawns are just way too strong
and someday this night will come back to
f5 folks I'm what I'm describing is just
a devastation
Black's position has
no chance of holding together this one
should end in a few moves I don't think
he'll last very long after King to g2
he's taking his time properly so let me
go back to this moment here properly so
is MDL you know when you have the fish
on the hook
mmm there are nug you ain't got a rush
he's thinking you're on the hook let me
just be patient and find the perfect
move at each point he doesn't want to
see any tricks but once he finds King g2
he plays it there is nothing for black
to do I'll show you how crazy it is I
saw a lot of the engine saying just play
Knight f6 and just just give that one up
too well you can't it's just completely
busted this position after takes takes
this was the position actually where
Knight f6 was suggested by the engine as
what else are you supposed to do because
this one is over we might see less than
five moves and this one B resigns to
results while we're on break no kidding
yes as a nice giri has drawn that end
game against alexandra christian did
field of like white hold down one
without any problems and dangler and has
drawn against heroes alex anko so this
is our current standings with of course
that key matchup still pending
Alexander Christian and Amish Duty
currently tied for well second place
with Maxine but we do expect the result
out of him with three and a half points
Fabiano Kurata is still playing as one
card if that is actually becoming more
and more sharp all right and those are
the two games that we have let's right
jump right into him
maurice has already given us an
explanation of how AVL is crushing it so
let's see how Bobby is doing of course a
lot of American fans in this broadcast
something's going on and I'm kind of
wondering this should and in some sort
of draw but there are lines I thought
this was a very good move by the way I
thought that that really actually in
some ways the onus on a be to force or
make the draw like I didn't feel to me
like weighing how was the one no the
let's say defensive side yeah I mean it
feels like weighing how in fact is the
one on the sunny side
actually precipitated bishop takes King
takes well you know I think fire has a
pretty key decision he could play Knight
d4 okay and that that looks kind of
equal to me you'll put preparing a fire
you probably have to take on um b2
because I know you're threatening to
make a queen by the way so I don't have
time to take your vision for the rook at
5:00 and it's protects f3 so this would
probably add in a draw and King takes me
to but I was wondering can you try night
III or is that asking too much of the
position let's have a look-see
only one move here for black because
otherwise rook air-five check rook takes
f3 trick will still pick up your Bishop
you do have to move that roof from f1 ok
laughs - okay fair enough
but on the other hand now as we know
grandmasters hate to put themselves in a
pin yeah you you wanted to I assumed
continue with this I'm actually not sure
what I want to do because I would love
to keep my rook on the F file but it
doesn't seem like I can actually do that
effectively right so something like this
where you would go ha ha it's very nice
now here you'll understand why I didn't
throw in the Moose III takes b2 King
takes me to with your King on a 2 I can
break the pin yeah and turn the tables
with Bishop d5 check so so that's why
you want you're not anxious I'm gonna
flip my Brooklyn at five yet I wanted to
play b4 and just see what is this any
game Wow
okay that's fast bombs must be pushed I
wanted to go King be freaking take c3 in
a good day you can't take on h2 let's
remember that right here rook takes h2
walks into that rook f5 check fall so
here we might be playing some way take
on h2 I was so anxious oh my goodness
sorry I was so anxious so I have to I
have to make even a more right maybe
this is a drop but this kind of
positions after for example I don't know
night high for something that was
absolute yeah this is actually getting
really really sharp suddenly I I thought
I was gonna have a nice quiet life in
some easy drawn looking game but you can
see
you know I'm gonna have to pass bonds
you're gonna have to pass bonds once you
collect c3 he's upon us a little faster
but it's an enough man man that's tough
that is tough and funnily enough you've
you somehow you-you-you arrested the
initiative yeah the advantage but we do
have a caller from Russia certain
onigiri let's get some really
interesting your turn sixty I know I
know I mean I'm trying to get it I'm
trying to take advantage of the senior
discounts you can play the senior
championship Evan yeah they changed the
dates a little bit has received an
official invitation right a nice jump
right tell us about your game today yeah
I was not too thrilled to the position I
had because I got this stupid isolated
pawn pretty much by force out of the
opening I mean I probably probably I
should try to keep the Queen's but I'm
not sure I can actually I didn't see how
I should do this because I have some
initiative here because I'm you know up
in development a little bit but I don't
I mean I'd see - I don't really remember
the move Queen g4 now I was thinking
maybe I should play some Queen e1 but I
was not so sure about various things I
mean it continues for example there's H
5 H 4 H 3 Queen g6 - 423 it's one thing
then maybe I can go g5 there Wow
that's if you take some [ __ ] so he gets
trapped but maybe he doesn't take on C -
yeah because it's also he's got gonna
have sex bishop or let's just put that
on the board viewers whoops
yeah there was sort of the line why I
got excited about it but then he has got
some 95 options various points before
you can do an inch sorry we just want to
update the game as we see is the key
game of the round Queen takes f4 and
Queen takes a7 has been played we do
have this between the grab and the
problem the QI and we're looking at king
e7 Queen c7 looks like complete
decimation as well as Queen b6 three
check to strong we'll keep an eye on
this one please anij continue with your
game so you were thinking about Queen e1
and each h4h three Queen G 6495 as a
line a possible line of play yeah -
Vanessa there were so many lies I didn't
really I wasn't really sure about
anything
at this point I was just I mean Blake
has lots of options instead as well I
mean he can also play it safe if he
wants of the Queen e1 he can even drop
back with Queen d7 or something if he
wants it safe but then of course I
probably couldn't even I don't know he's
got lots of options and also I mean he
can play Queen b6 if he wants I really
don't know there are a lot of lot of
moves I thought Bishop a4 is reasonably
clever because I'm you know I'm taking
with the a rook which is also yeah I'm
not sure why it's so good actually but
at least I'm developing pieces fast and
then maybe if I get de 45 quickly maybe
I will be slightly better because of you
know my advantage in development but
somehow it didn't really materialize in
the game sorry I just wanted to
interrupt you would take you back just
to a moment here it was here that Sasha
went into his patented deep think and he
came up with the move h7 h5 when he went
into such a tank did his eventual
decision at h5 surprise you at all yeah
yeah for sure I mean to be honest
93 I think is a new move but I'm not
sure if he was in book very possibly he
was trying to recollect it because I
think to play h5 and then after before
like the Queen before let me just
interrupt you for a moment and Maurice
has a breaking news for us Maurice yes
we do have a bizarre tactical
opportunity right now that has appeared
on the
or look at this rook check route f5
check King e6 and King a3 by Fabi and
look at this you don't see this every
day
he hasn't played position ideas to me
next time I interrupt you so you were
saying that h5 did not surprise you
sacrifice in the game of a piano it just
leads to total drawing position right so
I don't think it's much breaking this
that was great so H the point I think
that the two parts give us your you need
your reaction when you saw the move h5
what did you think I knew that this wife
is a very funny
I just didn't think it's likely because
you can also play castle as well which
is more much more natural right and okay
h5 I mean after d4 Edie Edie and you
think also you would expect like to play
h4 I thought and then I'd go d4 and but
this move Queen d4 is like I thought it
was way too subtle to to be found but he
found anyway strongly yeah it's a good
more I mean I have to misplace one of
the Knights in order to kick him out so
it's a good move ya know you have to
respect the subtlety yeah there was one
thing in the towards the end let's say a
nice nuance after takes Bishop c4 and
Bishop e6 all that the nice
yeah yeah here if I the thing is if I
don't 25 but if I make some move
I cannot say play a three after which if
you play is 95 no better example maybe
rookie one instead of a three as well
rookie one if you play is net amount 95
he cannot play but also after a three in
95 I've got this Bishop registry moves
in some lines after checking everything
I understand what you mean gotcha I was
sort of hoping to use this little
tactical opportunity to get something
here but he doesn't have to rush with
Bishop h3 here maybe after Bishop e6
maybe I have some something and this is
where you indicate that the move rook e1
might give you a nibble yeah but the
problem was that he I thought you can
let's say after a three or after rook e1
he's got Bishop d6 settled against
either a 300g one move any move he goes
Bishop e6 if I go Bishop g5 he's got it
should be seven back for example then I
was thinking maybe I have night of five
or something but then he can take it and
then maybe should be six yeah it's not
dilated trap but I was not sure it could
be an issue so you decided on d5
eventually this was wrong to be honest
with the King were only six for me but I
missed this move I mean I was focused on
takes Bishop c5 and I was trying to find
out once dr. Bishop c5 and I just forgot
he can sacrifice the a pawn all together
that was very convincing I mean here I'm
not fighting for anything I mean if
anything I should be I shouldn't be
ambitious here because the deep one is
really coming first exactly I we thought
that you should try to make the draws
starting from here exactly isin once you
don't once you realize you are not
playing for advantage and it's pretty
easy to to stay solid but yeah that was
not beautiful this is one of those cases
on each where both of you had calculated
this very long-winded
combination from d4 d5 but then at the
very end it's a question of judgment and
who stands better and it's easy for you
to think that well with your rook on b7
you can't be worse and maybe you can
press a little law that suddenly CA ya
know to be honest I felt it's not so
great but I just I didn't see I thought
if he goes Bishop d6 next it will be a
concluded bad position at least here I
might not be better but maybe he will
drift in on because I have long term
potential I've got the outside passer I
can bring the king to d3 so I didn't
feel like I'm doing very well but I
thought okay I'm not risking to lose and
let's see what happens exactly well now
of course the big day today is this game
between MDL and neppo six here so I'm
surprised Maurice is not interrupting us
[Laughter]
very very huge advantage or MDL and
likely he's going to win it that will
blow the treatment right wide open how
do you feel about your current situation
well I think what I see so far is that
basically as long as I start picking up
more points mm-hmm I will be fighting
for it so I'm not worried about the
other players at all I mean they are I
believe in them and I believe the
leaders will mess it up if needed but
the thing is that I have to start
winning more games because yeah you
cannot win tournament without doing more
game in against yourself so I think I
should be in the second half I should be
well hopefully getting more points and
then once I do that I think I'll get
there in the mix well this is your
second candidate you got your first
tournament victory in the candidates and
you said you felt your heart skip a beat
and you check with the doctor you're
you're still okay have a few you can
afford a few more victories without
suffering any major injury to your heart
yes that's the plan yeah I think
health-wise I'm ready for more wins
let's say yes very good I have a
question I wanted to echo a question of
one of the colors that came to us and he
was asking specifically about necklace
style in a match format do you think
that nepo is better suited for this kind
of tournaments where surprises are a
little bit more prevalent than in a
match format especially in some kind of
knockout or do you think that people
would be able to adjust very well and
play a great match for the world
champion if they qualified well it's
really very early early to tell I mean
certainly if he will win this tournament
despite today's setback not necessarily
saying from this yeah I mean Indian in
general if someone qualifies to the to
the Kali match that means he is a very
very good player very good under the
pressure as well because to win the
candidates takes a lot so I think any
player who you know who wins the
candidates undergo store transformation
which makes him automatically ready to
fight for the world title in some sense
so yeah obviously I mean in that sense I
think any player here
once he once he wins this tournament yes
I mean view so visa get crackin he was
not ready here actually a bad year and
then he won the candidates and suddenly
he was completely ready for the match
and he gave Magnus trivia run for his
money so I think certainly yeah if he on
wins he was ready but I if he will not
win he'll not be ready either so we saw
a galvan do the same thing as well
against once you go through this
grueling cycle and you come on top
you've got so much prep confidence and
everything that you are ready for for
the match I believe very good well on
each we want to thank you so very much
for joining us it was a pleasure to have
you on the air I know a lot of the
players have stated that they feel very
uncomfortable but I just want to say
that for us coming in this man in this
tournament is a real respite from our
self isolation to your players are the
players to those on the
ungrateful because I mean right now if
we speak about the situation in the
world and safety I mean I don't know
there are many places here if you sneeze
once or or cough or god forbid they will
immediately give you this test and
that's you know if you follow the news
these tests is really a it's not a given
you know in not in not in all countries
not available so easily and here if you
want you can get tested every day if you
have any issues at the same time you
have abundance of this mess I hear like
I took like I don't know like five now
with me up for where it's all so scarce
and the sanitizers I mean they're just
bottles and bottles here I mean no this
all these things and everybody is
feeling completely fine they do all
these tests they check the fever
everything and then after all does to be
complaining that you know you don't feel
like playing I mean I don't really see
the point here I think that it was good
to hear that Magnus gave a good
statement on this and said that you know
sort of defended the the tournament to
an extent and I think that I hope the
Challenger will also be a worthy worthy
one to Magnus and can also stand up for
chess in in this moment and not start
complaining about not being being here
and how how hard it is I mean it's
really just like and any other
tournaments and I mean I'm also unhappy
but I didn't win today and stuff but it
doesn't make we do have breaking news
from that she did resign as we expected
that has certainly transformed the
tournament completely on each I guess
he's not there anymore is he still with
us he's gone this this guy's is huge we
actually did see a few more moves get
played we saw one drastic move Queen d6
g5 he did take a rumpus on an after h5g
seven with a second Queen coming it
doesn't matter how you defend this
because II six is also a problem if your
Queen leaves let's say a Queen g5 for
example or the
very cruel queen f8 could be played as
well with the pawn promoting so this is
just completely over a real masterpiece
by MVL this is going to be one he's
extremely proud of but more importantly
for the tournament standings he is now
tied for first we have a completely
different tournament right now guys it
just broke wide open believable it means
the nipple gets just brought down that
important bag people even at 50% or I am
look you're just one point away from me
one victory against you puts me ahead of
you in the standings and take a look
it's max Eva sherrilyn grab there in
first place with still young upon
Bianchi but remember head-to-head and VL
is now ahead heat did Viviana and that
is the first tiebreaker
meanwhile Alexandra Chris Turk and
onigiri have 50% as well Fabiano karana
and one foul once they finish their game
because that is a hundred and ten
percent drawn give Alex ankle and ding
Lyra and meanwhile also split the points
and are on two and a half best
challenger to magnus carlsen that's a
tough question but that's what we're
here to find out this are their lifetime
records against Carlos on a belief EMV
l1 must be backwards because they gotta
be back no way no way Magnus I believe
that is 2 to 9 to the ninth exactly so
like our based on how they have played
against each other
it's Yan Yan is the one who would that's
traditionally done well against Magnus
at the last time no history is made to
be to remain in the past sometimes right
and you might see a number like that one
and think okay it's just overwhelmingly
the case but what was their last match
like the last match was in London and
they played for the Grand chest tour in
the semi finals and they came out of the
classical tide and then they went to the
first tie break and they were tied again
and they went again and finally was MVL
who defeated Magnus after one of the
most epic battles that you've ever seen
of course it wasn't over 12 classical
games
exactly and that's supremely important
different kind of thing but I would say
it's not gonna be like
when Fabi played against magnets and
people said it's gonna be all magnets in
the tiebreak come on he just had such a
dramatic edge MVL in a tie-break will
definitely hold up he would say yeah
he's got his great chances but could he
survive the relentless pressure of a
magnus carlsen hunting him down in the
night off and in the grünfeld but take a
look a grin fell I think is the one that
they may be more trouble for him now
guys this does set those up because
everybody it's a 50% is saying I'd be
one of these guys I'm back in it I'm
close I'm close
it's only a difference of one point and
what a matchup we have for you guys
tomorrow
oh you're sneaking ahead I was leading I
had it just a little bit sorry there are
the correct numbers due tonight of
course favoring Magnus Carlsen
throughout their history in classical
chess a lot of draws the komyatti 41
advantage against Carlsen with six draws
of course they are players that know
each other very well necklace actually
worked for Magnus in the past world
championship cycle as well let's take a
sneak look at that round eight pairing
oh my what do we have there Bianca
Corona with the white pieces against max
Eva Charla graph exactly the same
situation mvl was today against nepo one
point behind and with white must-win
game for Fabi exactly and yon looking at
unleash and Anisha was just on our show
and again a big shout-out thank you a
niche for joining us he's looking at
that match and saying look if I can just
get one point one win that could be tied
for first by the way we've got a local
caller probably saying is not it's not
Egypt
good morning st. Louis I please tell us
your name and your question yeah my name
is Joe I'm from st. Louis as you guys
said I'm gonna kind of echo what you
guys were talking about with Anisha and
in as much as I try to follow the chest
it's way above me but you guys this
skill level is so much different do you
see differences in play
with all the concern over the
coronavirus hmm they are the play
Maurice are the players being affected
by the stresses that are going on in the
world I can't see that not being
affected whether or not their play has
been substantially altered as a result
it looks like a candidate's to me it
looks like what you look at the way the
candidates girls it looks like a
candidates missed opportunities here and
there a brilliant moves as well so it's
very hard for me to say if we eliminated
the candidates say we're not seeing some
really great games and some mistakes now
there may be someone like a ding
Lorraine for example who might have been
more concerned in the early side of this
when China was was really feeling the
pressure and who knows what family and
friends that he was worried about so
that I would say the most surprising
part of it
Fabiano Cara Juana looks like he's not
quite himself either so maybe that is
the case but I think it's hard it's just
really impossible to judge by the way
there has been a result here his game
did end in a draw the rook sacrifice
that we talked about earlier it was
played on c2 and we have our final
results so this we got a war on our
hands a brawl folks a one-point lead by
two players and by the way the history
is still on net both side history says
nobody comes over him a point down
maxime Russian magrav would have to
break that recent history and keep this
up but nepo needs to right the ship we
know we've seen him do this before
take a big lead early and then trip up
and then keep tripping he can't do that
here he needs to right the ship and then
make a run in the second half to take
over the lead once again well look at
that knee she's very confident he knows
that this by being blocked tomorrow and
that put just lost and right the type of
player that loses in a row right if he
can put a victory tomorrow with black
frogs over nipple yeah actually it
doesn't deal with tie their head-to-head
and then we have more complicated
tiebreaks right but that would put it
back in the running I think yeah we
leapfrog over Knepper I think you said
it right that's yeah Napo can't afford
start losing games because
start counting opposed losses again and
an itch would be would be going forward
in a brisk way so that's a big matchup
but winning with black is going to be a
tall order for sure for sure and Bobbie
winning with white not such a tall order
so if they if those two can actually win
we'd have a massive tie at the top what
kind of result would that be after eight
rounds right now let's put this together
once again for the format it's a double
round-robin so the players have played
through a complete cycle seven games
we've finished the first half of chess
over exactly and now they go into the
second part of that double round-robin
the players will play against one
another in the same order that they did
previously
they'll just flip the colors so that
everybody gets black and white I'm not a
hundred percent sure about that if the
same order because I think that would
give somebody three whites or three
blacks if I remember correctly oh yeah
they actually have to switch it up a
little bit but I'll confirm that in a
second yeah but they definitely in the
second half of the event now and those
had to have matchups become very very
important and let's take a look at we
needed the smart guys the smart guys in
the room we needed some validation
tomorrow good if Bobby wins you're still
only tied okay I get you or the
tiebreaker could be ahead but at the
moment it looks like some people are
just a little bit more astute than
others this all I'm side the way I think
Bobby needs to put together a really
convincing game yeah I mean we talked
about the Challenger earning it going
out there and taking it Bobby has not
played the type of game that brought him
victory in the Tata Steel where it was
just magnificent so I'm ready for fabbi
to put together a really great game I'm
ready for him to wake up he needs some
wins somebody needs some wins if they're
gonna challenge ivl an apple they're
currently tied for first of course and
with that slight edge over nap on the
night breaks but it's still plenty of
chess I did confirm they don't play in
the same order it is very similar order
but not exactly the same and of course
you've got to avoid the Russians playing
each other on the last plane Maxime in
the final round that's a very important
question I know that blazingly run with
black in the final round on MBL place
one Colin the final round was bite all
right so that means their revenge match
will come earlier based on that well
that's going to be interesting if I may
say you know this was certainly a big
day we we wanted we didn't know whether
or not nvl totally needed to win this
one but he acted like it and he
delivered on call to say all right now
we're tied and I'm ahead of you on time
breaks after seven magnificent play by
him to be sure what a great game on his
part by the way just when we're thinking
about we came in today we said look this
game between MBL and neppo was our
marquee matchup where do we really feel
that something went wrong for neppo we
said like okay now you know like the
opening hasn't worked out when did it
Wendy the are the finger feller castling
bothered me and then the game opened up
it just seemed like he had a bad version
of this position and he couldn't get his
way out of it after that night landed on
d7 so you reckon even c4 for sure
c4 definitely for step in the wrong
direction yeah you're shutting down a
position and you have no play right but
but even before that I'm concerned for
his position know this this king and
rook on that side that just left a
really poor impression I don't know how
you improve when you pawn his attacks
but the king it was on that side boy
that was a that was a big problem maybe
ninety seven years you're targeting
there could have been a poor move well
that was where I really felt like
throughout the game in fact that the
night on d7 turned out to be just really
in the wrong square like forever and
later it really turned out that the
night would have been so much more
useful had it landed on the c6 square
because 97 is the top engine move I mean
none of these moves are knew this was
all standard play up until I don't know
if it's standard play but I know I've
seen the position either from analysis
or first from something I know I know 97
is the engine recommendation okay
well we'll just tell me where you think
that boy at this moment at that moment
now I really knew that white was for
choice mode I saw rookie change the
problem is kind of positions the engine
very often gives fine for black and then
I play three moves on my own and then
it's just dead ran this is what kind of
positions that we consider to be very
dangerous for a human player right where
if you play but before I finish that
thought we have our friend the man of
the hour max Eva share the graph with us
he has just defeated Jana poetry in the
French dear friends how did you do it
hey it was cool so first of all yes sir
happy belated birthday thank you thank
you my friend
yeah and yeah I wish I could say this
was the only reason I was joining you
steak but no I actually played a good
game and we're having it try to figure
out where did it go wrong for an f1
we're having trouble deciphering exactly
where his position started to turn bad
well he thought for a long time to play
c4 and I mean this position is a bit
worse see so were you happy to see c5 c4
wait a second there's an interview going
on so we have to take some assistance
there from Leonard
Oh Tess yes yes so help us out where did
where did it at the certain moment you
said my goodness I like my position when
did that happen
I didn't like to see for I think like
maybe King he ate it's very sad to have
to break in the 1880s e7 but and also it
can run into some seen before at some
point maybe I sort of so who takes b1
first actually context b1 Qin a6 was the
way to play she leaned that King in the
center keeping an eye on e to so you
don't make any size may be doing time
already to place it with the skinny
eight or maybe 96 night c4 at some point
I thought this should be reasonable
black I like that idea of 94 because we
saw how bad and I was on d7 throughout
the game and something on c4 it actually
has a happy spot yeah so when he plays
see for the night on d7 I'm not gonna
end up on the C 4 square anymore so no
it's understand about to cross the
center because if you take tags and
Bishop before comes with quite effect
but I think it was just wrong here
so c4 castled yeah and I found this
great idea of giving objections yeah
yeah we were very very impressed with
your decision to play f4 and sacrificing
the exchange yeah but if you take on 2x
Queen a6 b5 Queen d7 appreciate doesn't
matter graphite it just looks plain
awful exactly your pieces into the game
and the rook on h8 is a pretty sad
spectator yeah no I think just sad yeah
yes from weekend basics I mean the
weekend I hate actually want for h7 so
it's not doing like like if blacks
Knight was only 7 of course
it would be a fight but not not cutting
it
Maxie were you surprised to see a French
get played a little bit but you played
it already in the tournament so I had to
be ready for it right now when he played
the move knight c6 take us through your
thought process is it at this point
because on the one hand your fainting
that you want to play G for f5 and then
the other hand you came up with rook on
f1 to be one was wrong because of for
instance g6 mm-hmm or even f5 is
playable so in both cases I wasn't no f5
for black yeah and yeah you didn't want
to play g4 we were looking at a position
like this where okay when I black is
suddenly no I thought could be one is
the way to go and I can I mean of course
he wants a fight but I'm happy to let
him because of this idea was chief
accordion and I thought it was very bad
for him
maybe there's drawer somewhere but I
doubt it after g4 I think it's nice over
yeah we we saw your play it was so crisp
and straightforward at this point we
were actually calling the game for you
there's a tree there's a very important
point though I like take take take take
on f5 they can be one can be one Queen
b6 if can be six is very important that
I have f6 I think very important that
you have F six seven yeah but I probably
should just take her make six is my
night was always covering for any sort
of Perpetual song yeah I don't think
anything can do here was black it was
actually funny in the game that the
night on g3 covered all the perpetual
it's 2h visas not even one check so
exactly your great defender of the night
is only two exactly that looks like a
very nice smooth win for you which is
why he took night g3 Queen b6 yes and
sure it's important this Queen a one
move yeah because when a token busy
would be unclear and after Queen 81 if
he goes couldn't be 393 that's just not
even a check ever and is a pawn is not
moving forward
exactly just one last moment so after
kin G 2 G 6 yeah Queenie 6 Nigeria Queen
ji ho Kim G 2 G 6 okay the chance
because if I take H 5 it's already
getting okay but Queen a3 is very strong
Queen a3 check yes yes to work in the
AIDS and open d6 ha ha pawn takes c6 and
it doesn't matter where you go with the
night can be a concern it's it's not
that it's good enough a nice puzzle rush
it's the same story in just f5 and then
can be a Queen c7 or can be a tough six
it may be a 5h for couldn't be 87
probably couldn't be 7e Quincy Sun works
but that six was what a yeah Queen c7 of
course yeah a 27 but Queenie a checking
this is queen of freedoms and a queen G
stoppages and king of six Queen of AIDS
and
no I mean kingi 628 can give six Queen
of fate although it's essentially the
same but at least you took the pawn on
e6 yeah nice nice nice variations it's
all looking very pretty for you you
expect doesn't have a check for rock
removes any of these postponed so you
expect there to be something exactly
absolutely I took my time to break in g2
because I could pay king edge to to
avoid this g6 h5 I mean artist to to
make it less powerful but in g2 is just
more natural and the queen is 26 I
realized I'm just winning
maxime I have a question for you going
at this round
did you see this as must-win no other
options I gotta go for it I've gotta
beat this guy today nice - maybe not but
you know at some point I do have to win
games and it's it would have been a good
thing to do it against the leader so
yeah actually this was a crucial game
but it's only after tournaments so you
know many many things can happen from
Yemen well very very nice when magazine
our congratulations it really makes the
tournament that much more interesting
and you you just blew the tournament
wide open makes it great but you know
again it's only of summed up time like
even in football you can read by by
three or four girls and you know or you
can be wait I don't remember you know
the super bowl from two years ago so I
know it was no like
doing Louise England yeah yeah it was a
big at the house I was down big at the
half and everybody was counting them out
until Brady came back with magic but but
I do have another question for you
now that it's even we're calling
tomorrow's game against Fabi as a huge
must-win game for Fabi what's your
attitude going into that game well I'll
just be ready if I play the way I played
in general in the first half you know I
won't be unhappy and then and because
I'm that means that if you beat me it
will look great over a really great game
absolutely I just wanted to say one
other thing I know that there's been a
lot of criticism whether the tournament
should have been cancelled or not but I
do want to say that for us and suffering
in self-isolation you're bringing a
great respite into our lives we look
forward to the tournament to coming here
to the club and you know commentating on
your games otherwise our lives would be
very very boring without the story
taking place in Russia yeah I know it's
it's wet times but I mean as
professional players we just have to
keep focused on the tournament ends I
mean for one I think I managed yes you
are so good thank you very much see you
congratulations on your victory what a
great one it was and certainly lining up
our days absolutely all right thank you
again for joining yes thank you max
thank you and again that's the round
tomorrow at the second half of the
tournament round 8 and Fabiano Kurata
who's been pretty disappointing this
tournament so far 50% will be facing
against max Eva Charlotte graph and a
win would change everything in this
tournament and he needs it and he needs
it but look at that individual matchup
those guys have really taken the measure
of one
and here the all the pairings for round
8 and let's look at yong upon me
actually the other leaderless I'm gonna
be playing is onigiri he's white does he
wanna risk and string together some kind
of rebound or is he gonna risk for
falling apart he's done it before
in Grantchester especially in Croatia
but he's a strong player I'm certainly I
certainly know that he can pick himself
back up after a loss the question is
will he be able to do so tomorrow and
there it is
that's the question and here's our
tournament as current standings and
again we're not seeing too much social
distancing no there's a two-point gap
between first and last and for the
people in last making up two points and
seven rounds that's certainly difficult
fun everybody there on third place is
looking out those leaders with hunger in
their eyes they know that I went against
any of them will be absolutely crucial
Murray's jump in with their final
thoughts of the day well I know you
spoke to the players about us having a
respite you know this this being the
opportunity for the world to take a look
and say we're having a good time being
able to watch some chance the best
players go at it that's how I feel you
get to come to to work and be able to
call these great players you get games
like this that where the the cream rises
to the top in maxime playing a boss game
suddenly there's all this drama in the
tournament with leaders we get an itch
coming on and and roasting us in a
moment you just you're any idea how much
fun it is to be able to be able to do
this job and we still have seven more
rounds this is awesome this is as good
as it gets and with a big dog matchup
again tomorrow
Bobby versus mvl we can look forward to
getting a good good day good night's
rest and then more amazing chess well
thank you very is just pointing out that
us is too many people
well I wanted to say that coming back
after the rest day to that the players
really did bring it was funny because
for me the game of Fabiano you know I
wanted to see more he had the white
pieces today against you know so well
because he's played it with black in
such great games and so I expected him
to show why the Petra often has some
issues he didn't he didn't impress it is
maybe tomorrow maybe tomorrow we'll see
he is white again so it's important for
him I went tomorrow
or hope for the best and at that point
you're really relying on the other
players right yes that was a US
Championship Cambridge Springs was very
nice a nice event I believe Michael
Wilder was the US Champion that year so
thank you all thank you for all of the
email and best wishes I just wanted to
say it was a great game it wasn't want
to echo maurices thoughts this is what
the candidates is all about this is why
we love these tournaments absolutely see
you tomorrow guys we will be back with
more action straight from your
contouring work
don't miss it thank you for joining us
[Music]
[Music]